He responds.
[Music]
I recently did a commentary on the David
Wood and Alex Okconor debate,
particularly on the Q&A section because
I was there and I was able to ask a
question and Alex gave his response and
his argument was on whether or not Jesus
pre-existed as the angel of the Lord.
And he used Hebrews 1 to object to that
concept. And so I did commentary on
that. And so you could check out that
video. And Alex actually responded. He
actually had a lot to say. So, we're
going to break this up into parts just
like the Quran. Take a look. Hey, thanks
for the question and the video, but I
think your entire premise here is
faulty. You say that I claimed Hebrews
itself has a lowristologology denying a
pre-incarnate son. Gives the
timestamps. I never
denied that Hebrews has a high
christologology. Of course, it does. The
whole project of Hebrews 1 is highly
exalting Christ as separate from the
angels after establishing his
pre-existence. The debate was about
Jesus's claims. So I would not mention
in that context. This makes your
commentary here on Hebrews 1, while
perfectly sensible, irrelevant to my
case. I brought Hebrews up only to
specifically discuss whether Christians
should think Jesus is the angel of
Yahweh in Exodus, not to imply that the
text had a low christologology. You
suggest that I was using Hebrews to
disprove a pre-incarnate son. That would
be an insane take on the angel of Yahweh
itself. Your original response, Hebrews
11:26, remains an interesting retort,
but I still don't think it confirms
Jesus as the angel in Exodus. It may do.
Perhaps you're right. Which would be a
really interesting fact, though, of
course, still not establishing anything
about Jesus's own claims. But I don't
think it's conclusive. Nothing in this
response video indicates Jesus is the
angel in Exodus either. Shout out to
Alex for giving us a thoughtful
response. Um, and I just can't wait to
see him in person because this really is
an interesting topic. And it's wild for
you to say, Alex, that nothing in the
previous video indicates that Jesus is
the angel in Exodus. That's wild, man.
And here's why. I'm glad that you
acknowledge that Jesus, according to
Hebrews 1,
pre-existed, right, as God's son,
separate and exalted over the angels.
Um, I'm glad that you highlight that,
but that same point is what you're
missing. Who Jesus pre-existed as is the
point. That's the very point. The fact
that he pre-existed as the son, who
reveals the father, who makes the father
known, who created all things and
created the heavens and the earth, who
is
unchanging. That right there shows you
who he was back then, being active with
the prophets, revealing himself to the
prophets. For example, your point was
that, you know, God spoke to the
prophets in many ways, right? But in
these last days, he speaks to us through
his son. However, that doesn't mean that
he wasn't also speaking to the prophets
through his son. It literally says this,
"Long ago, at many times, and in many
ways, God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets. But in these last days, he has
spoken to us by his son, whom he
appointed the heir of all things,
through whom also he created the
worlds." Notice how it says that God
spoke at many times and in many ways to
our fathers by the prophets. Right?
That's now how does he speak by the
prophets? You have the angel of the Lord
coming to the prophets. Right? You have
many ways that God is speaking by the
prophets to the fathers. And so this
doesn't negate that one of those many
ways is the son. Just like in these last
days, he's spoken to us by his son. That
doesn't negate that he also uses
prophets as well. Because literally
Jesus says in Matthew 23, he says,
"Therefore, I send you prophets and
scribes." And we see in the book of Acts
that prophets are around and they're
being used to speak to Paul, for
example, and others. Prophets are still
being used, but the revelation is
through the sun. So, it's not negating
that the son was speaking back then in
the book of Hebrews. Now, since we
acknowledge that Jesus pre-existed
according to Hebrews, Hebrews 11:26 puts
Jesus in the time of Moses where Moses
feared his reproach, where Moses feared
the disapproval of Christ. Well, who was
there traveling with Moses? Who's the
one who revealed himself to Moses? Who's
the one that commanded Moses to leave
Egypt? That is the angel of the Lord. If
you ask Moses who he saw and who was he
talking to, who was he revering, he
would have said the angel of Yahweh.
Yahweh himself. You asked the writer of
Hebrews who Moses was in fear of, who
did he receive commands from? The writer
of the Hebrews would say, "Oh, that was
Jesus." Alex goes on a little further to
say this. In case of interest, here are
some considerations. One, Hebrews 11 is
a chapter about faith and hope in what
is unseen. It opens, now faith is the
confidence in what we hope for and
assurance about what we do not see. It
goes on to say of Moses, he regarded
disgrace for the sake of Christ as of
greater value than the treasures of
Egypt because he was looking ahead to
his reward. The author here is certainly
placing Jesus in the time of Moses,
which makes sense in his
christologology, but it is not clear
exactly how or in what way. It's
definitely interesting, but certainly
not clear that the author thinks Jesus
is the angel of
Yahweh. Just as John's author has a
pre-existent logos, but he does not
identify it with any Old Testament
messenger, neither does Hebrews, despite
Jesus's
pre-existence. What? It's not clear who
else was there in the presence of Moses
who Moses was revering, receiving
commands from and told him to leave
Egypt, it's Yahweh. Matter of fact, if
we're specific on who it is that gave
the commands to Moses in Exodus 3, this
is what it says starting at verse two.
And the angel of the Lord appeared to
him in a flame of fire out of the midst
of the bush. He looked, and behold, the
bush was burning, yet it was not
consumed. And Moses said, "I will turn
aside to see this great sight, why the
bush is not burned." When the Lord saw
that he turned aside to see, God called
to him, "Out of the bush, Moses, Moses."
And he said, "Here I am." Then he said,
"Do not come near. Take your sandals off
your feet, for the place on which you
are standing is holy ground." And he
said, "This is the angel of the Lord
being identified as God, saying, I am
the God of your father, the God of
Abraham, the God of Isaac, and the God
of Jacob." And Moses hid his face, for
he was afraid to look at God. So, who
was it that gave the command to Moses to
leave Egypt to take the people of Israel
out of Egypt so that they may worship
him? Who was it that was there that gave
the commands to Moses that freed him,
that appeared to him? It was the angel
of the Lord. That's the one whom Moses
feared, didn't want to disgrace, didn't
want to have his disapproval. Hebrews
says that was Christ. It's clear as day.
And just to be clear that the writer of
Hebrews is not saying that Jesus was not
speaking through the prophets uh in
verse one, here are some verses in
Hebrews as we look Hebrews chapter 2
verse
10 to13. This is what it says here. For
it was fitting that he for whom and by
whom all things exist in bringing many
sons to glory should make the founder of
their salvation perfect through
suffering. For he who sanctifies and
those who are sanctified all have one
source. That is why he is not ashamed to
call them brothers,
saying, "I will tell of your name to my
brothers. In the midst of the
congregation, I will sing your praises,
and again, I will put my trust in him.
And again, behold, I and the children
God has given me." So the writer of
Hebrews has Jesus directly speaking,
quoting the Psalms, applying it to
Jesus. So Jesus speaking through the
prophets in the Old Testament. Here we
go again in Hebrews chapter 10:es 5 to8.
Consequently, when Christ came into the
world, he said, "Sacrifices and
offerings you have not desired, but a
body have you prepared for me. In burnt
offerings and sin offerings you have
taken no pleasure." Then I said,
"Behold, I have come to do your will, oh
God, as it is written of me in the
scroll of the book." When he said above,
"You have neither desired nor taken
pleasure in sacrifices and offerings and
burnt offerings and sin offerings, these
are offered according to the law." So
when we look at the book of Hebrews as a
whole, we clearly see that they display
Jesus speaking, communicating in the Old
Testament before he takes on flesh. So
there's no way in the world that Hebrews
1 is negating that Jesus was speaking in
the Old Testament or speaking through
the prophets by or that God was using
the son to speak in any way. He spoke in
various ways. He goes on to say this
two, Hebrews has a tendency of taking OT
concepts and applying them to Jesus even
though the Old Testament passage was not
about Jesus at all. Most interesting
here is Hebrews 1:8. But about the son,
he says, "Your throne, oh God, will last
forever and ever. A scepter of justice
will be the scepter of your kingdom."
This quotes Psalm 45 in which the title
God is given human king who is getting
married. A footnote in the NIV for oh
God here says here the king is addressed
as God's representative which is really
interesting in the context of this
debate. You say that since Hebrews
quotes a psalm in which Lord is applied
to Jesus but in the psalm referred to
Yahweh, Hebrews must be saying Jesus is
Yahweh. By that logic since the psalm
quoted immediately prior applies God to
Jesus but in the psalm it refers to an
earthly king. Hebrews is saying that
Jesus is that earthly married king. That
can't be right. I just have to say if
you think, Alex, that Psalm 45 is
talking about just some mere earthly
king, some mere human earthly king who's
married. My guy, you are missing the
mark here. First of all, let me show you
and the indications one that he's not
just a merely earthly king. And it's not
simply that he's called God referred to
as Elohim. That that that's not
necessarily just it because he's not
just simply God's representative. He
himself is God. And let me show you why.
Because in verse 11, it says this about
the king, about the bride. Says, "Let
the king be enthralled by your beauty.
Honor him for he is your Lord. Now why
is this significant? This ex this is
significant because in the Hebrew the
words here for he is your Lord is
adonic.
Adoni. Now why is this significant?
Because this happens only once. This
shows up only one other place and that
is in Isaiah 51 verse 22 and this phrase
is used. It says thus
says Adonic your Lord
Yahweh your God. This is the only time
this this word is used to refer to
someone. elsewhere. It's Yahweh, God,
the Lord, and it's used for this king
described in Psalm 45. This isn't just
some mere human earthly king. This is
Yahweh. Another nugget here in Psalm 45
verse 17 is what it says here. It says,
"I will perpetuate your memory through
all generations. Therefore, the nations
will praise you forever and ever. The
nations will praise you. Not just
Israel, but all the nations, the gentile
nations will praise this king who is
Yahweh, Adon, Adon, who has a term
referred to only for Yahweh. The nations
will praise him. Why is this
significant? Because one, you do not
have a Davidic king where all the
nations praised. You do not have a king
in Israel of all of Israel where all the
nations were subject to and all the
nations praised and ga and gave him
honor. This is messianic. This is of the
Messiah. Which is why a lot of the
rabbis interpret this as being
exclusively of the Messiah. And mind
you, this is written after Solomon. This
is after Solomon. This can't this ain't
talking about Solomon. They talking
about no other king other than the
messianic king who all nations will will
praise, sing his praises. Does that
sound familiar? Sounds like the son of
man in Daniel 7. Who is given glory and
honor and kingdom, right? And majesty
forever and ever. And all the nations,
all peoples and tongues and languages
will serve him. It's the same guy. Now,
you really emphasize the fact that this
king in Psalm 45 is married as if that
cancels out that it could be talking
about Christ because Christ wasn't
married while he was here, right? Well,
let's look at who Christ identifies
himself to be. Not just him, but also
John the Baptist. Look at what this says
here in John 3 27- 29. John the Baptist
speaking says John answered a person
cannot receive even one thing unless it
has been given from him from heaven. You
yourself bear witness bear me witness
that I said I am not the Christ but I
have been sent before him. The one who
has the bride is the
bridegroom. The friend of the bridegroom
who stands and hears him rejoices
greatly at the bridegroom's voice.
Therefore, this joy of mine is now
complete. So, what is John saying? John
the Baptist is saying that Jesus is the
bridegroom and he has the bride. He's
the friend that's happy for the
bridegroom. He's rejoicing for him. So,
Jesus is the
bridegroom. Now, let's continue reading.
Let's see what else it says about Jesus.
This is Mark chapter 2 starting at verse
18. says, "Now John's disciples and the
Pharisees were fasting, and people came
and said to him, why do John's disciples
and the disciples of the Pharisees fast,
but your disciples do not fast?" And
Jesus said to them, "Can the wedding
guests fast while the bridegroom is with
them? As long as they have the
bridegroom with them, they cannot fast."
So Jesus himself identifies himself as
the bridegroom just like John the
Baptist says that he is the bridegroom.
Let's continue this thought here.
Ephesians chapter 5. Now this is
beautiful. This is watch what this says
here. Husbands love your wives as Christ
loved the church and gave himself up for
her. I challenge you guys to find any
verse like this in the Quran. Oh strays.
Islam catches strays. that he might
sanctify her, having cleansed her by the
washing of water with the word, so that
he might present the church to himself
in splendor without spot or wrinkle or
any such thing, that she might be holy
and without blemish. In the same way,
husbands should love their wives as
their own bodies. He who loves his wife
loves himself. For no one ever hated his
own flesh, but nourishes and cherishes
it just as Christ does the church
because we are members of his body.
Therefore, a man shall leave his father
and mother and hold fast to his wife and
the two shall become one flesh. This
mystery is profound and I am saying that
it refers to Christ and the church. So
with Christ being the
bridegroom, who's the bride of Christ?
It is the church. It's the body of
believers. So of course, Psalm 45
depicts this king with splendor and
majesty who all nations will serve. Who
gives gives him a term that belongs to
Yahweh alone,
Adonai, and identifies him who is
married, a married king. And who is the
bride of Christ? It's the body of
believers. the believers. That by the
way also include the gentile nations who
he saves. The gentile nations who will
come into the truth, come into his
palace and worship and serve him and the
father by the spirit. There's no way
Psalm 45 is talking about anybody else.
So yes, Jesus is Yahweh who created the
heavens and the earth, who is
unchanging, whose years will not end
according to Hebrews chapter 1 10 to12
quoting Psalm 102. Yes, referring to him
as Lord, which would be Kios, referring
to Yahweh in the Old Testament. And he
is that righteous king who is identified
as God. Full of splendor and majesty,
ruling with righteousness, who is
married to the church, presents the
church as his own bride, splendor
without blemish because of his blood,
who all nations will serve and sing his
praises because he has saved them and
has brought them in into his fold. Did
not leave them out. Did not isolate them
even though they were not originally his
people. That is the Messiah. Alex
continues and says, "So Hebrews takes
Psalm 45, which is not about Jesus, but
a human at his wedding, and repurposes
it for his high christoologgical
exposition. It wouldn't surprise me if a
similar thing is occurring in Hebrews
11." Number three, Hebrews says, "God
spoke in these last days by his son
through whom he created the world." As
you state, the author clearly has a
pre-existent son here, which I never
denied. But that does not change the
fact that the son did not speak to
humanity until these last days which
remains a strange thing to say if the
author thought Jesus had spoken to Moses
through the burning bush. Alex again you
are reading that into the text. It does
not say that the son did not speak in
the past through the prophets. Remember
the verse says that God spoke in various
ways and in many
times by the prophets to our fathers.
What are the various ways that God spoke
by the prophets? One of those ways is
through the son which was demonstrated
in Hebrews chapter 2 and Hebrews chapter
10. It does not negate that the son
spoke in the times of old by
highlighting that he's speaking in these
times. Just like it doesn't negate that
God is speaking through prophets in
these times like he did of old. Which is
why again Jesus says, "I send you
prophets." In Matthew 23:36, he
continues, "There is of course more to
say, but the main thing I want to
emphasize is that I absolutely do not
think Hebrews denies a pre-existent son,
nor does it have a low Christology, nor
did I ever claim as such. That's why I
say in the Q&A that I have no problem
saying that Hebrews has a high
christologology, but clarify that I
don't know about the angel of Yahweh. I
wish I'd have been clearer, but I
definitely didn't make the claims you
said I did in your video. I also don't
think you have established here that
Hebrews identifies Jesus as the angel in
Exodus. If there are reasons I'm missing
for identifying Jesus as the angel, I'm
all ears. I don't like how interesting
discussions can get lost in debate
formats and this is a fascinating topic
even if peripheral to Jesus's own
claims. I would like to say this, Alex,
that one, I do appreciate your approach
to this. The way that you are um
addressing these issues, I I love it.
You uh seem to be intellectually honest.
you know, when an interesting point is
brought to you, you have no problem
acknowledging it and looking further
into it. Which is why, man,
um I I thank you for clarifying that you
you were clear. And you're right. You
did not say that Hebrews has a low
christologology. You never said that.
You never deny that it teaches a pre um
existent son. You're just objecting to
him being the angel of Yahweh of the Old
Testament. Um, and so this is why we
don't use one verse to come up with a
doctrine, right? Obviously, I believe
that Hebrews 11:es 25 to 26 definitely
shows that Jesus is the angel of Yahweh.
Um, when it puts Jesus in Moses's time
as the one who he fears disapproval of.
However, I wouldn't just use that verse
alone. We will look at the totality of
the New Testament, the totality of the
Old Testament, and come to the
conclusion, look at, you know, use
proper hermeneutics to conclude that
Jesus is indeed the angel of Yahweh.
Which is why, you know, I'm going to be
in London pretty soon. And I would love
for us to have this conversation. Let's
talk about whether or not Jesus is the
angel of Yahweh. Does the scripture
teach this? Does the scripture display
and portray Jesus as the angel of
Yahweh? Let's talk about it. On another
note, I hope that you guys enjoyed this
video. If you guys want to check out my
previous video where this is all
stemming from, it's down in the link
below in the description. Also, like and
subscribe and check out the other
videos. If you guys like these type of
breakdowns, let me know. Put in the
comments section if you guys think good
points were made. What do you guys think
about the points Alex made? Let us know
in the comments section. See you guys in
the next video. Oh my god.
[Music]
logic. Hey